One Thursday morning, several summers ago,
I woke up and started scrolling
through social media
like so many of us do every morning.
What caught my eye that morning, though,
was an article about how 100,000
people in Detroit
were about to have to live
without running water
because they couldn't afford
their water bills.
And people have been living
with this issue for a while.
And they get by.
They were doing everything
from collecting rainwater in barrels
to walking to relative's houses
to take showers every few days.
And much worse, sometime later,
I learned that a lot of people
were actually losing custody of their kids
because they couldn't afford
to pay their water bills.
Instead of someone helping them,
they just lost their kids.
For many of them, their greatest
transgression, you could argue,
was that they were either
elderly, disabled,
had just been laid off
or worked jobs that simply
didn't pay enough.
And yes, I said jobs.
And to me, how they were being treated
and the level of contempt shown to them
and how easy it was to simply deny them
something that we all need to live
was disgusting.
(Applause)
It's disgusting.
But to me this also felt personal,
even though I have
no direct family ties to Detroit.
And here's why.
Many of the people
who were facing shut offs were Black.
Many were also like myself, Black women.
And Lord knows it's not the first time
in the United States
that Black people have been denied
basic human rights like water.
So to me, that created
an overwhelming urge
to do something to help.
I mean, I couldn't just read that
and then go on about my day.
Then it became a question
of what can I,
sitting in my pajamas
as one person at home, actually do?
Well, what?
Oh, oh, but wait.
I'm a programmer.
And a heavy, heavy social media user.
So I decided to tweet.
To tweet what I was reading about,
what I was seeing, how I felt,
to my online community
of activists, politicians,
start-up founders and investors.
Some like yourselves.
And other programmers, of course.
And over the course of a few hours
of back and forth about what to do,
we resolved to do the simplest,
most obvious thing
that would help somebody
in this situation.
We decided to pay some water bills.
To do that, I skipped work that day.
I did not go to work that day.
And instead,
I spent a few hours digging around
on the water company's website.
And I found something interesting
that sort of jump-started
what to do for people.
For some reason, there was a 400-page PDF
of customers on the website
that the water company couldn't deliver
their bills to through the mail,
and some of these
were delinquent accounts.
But one of the things
that was interesting about this list
is that it also included
account numbers for people.
So you just take one
of those account numbers
and, at that time, plug it
into the website
and see everything about that account.
So I did that.
And one of the things
that was interesting, though, there,
was that I saw a "make a payment" button.
So the idea then became, what if we
got the account numbers of people
that needed help and then
made payments for them?
So a few hours later,
I built a website to find those people
and start connecting them
to people that needed help.
And then I tweeted that.
And to keep things simple,
people who wanted to help
simply would get instructions
on how to log onto the utility's website
as if they were the account holder
and just make payments.
And then once they had done that,
they would send us the receipts
and we would send those to the families
that had gotten the help.
And empowered with those donations,
with those payments,
they were able to go to the water company
and advocate for themselves
and demand that their water
be turned back on.
And in doing that,
that's how, in the first 40
or so days of doing this,
we paid over 100,000 dollars
in water bills by just simply --
(Applause)
Thank you.
By just simply sending people directly
to the utility company's website
to pay five dollars, 10 dollars.
Whatever they could afford.
And I don't say that to brag,
but instead to encourage you all
to notice problems
and to think about what is the simplest,
most obvious thing you can do
to impact that problem.
So first, what I’ll also say
that was true for us,
is that it should be abundantly clear
that whatever you do
doesn't actually have to be perfect.
You don't have to do some big
overarching thing like a nonprofit.
Because you won’t have
all the answers when you start.
But what's beautiful about that
is that you don't actually need
to have all the answers to get started.
And I will confess
that if we had had all the answers,
if we had known too much,
we might not have actually gotten started.
So the next thing that's true is that ...
When you put together and you start
doing something that's imperfect
and it's not finished,
people will see what you're doing
and they'll want to join you.
They'll want to get together with you
to make what you're doing bigger,
more impactful, more meaningful,
but all in ways unique to themselves.
For us, that was the city employees
who answered our emails on weekends.
And then during the week,
drove people to appointments
to get their water turned back on.
It was the people in mutual-aid
groups and nonprofits
that partnered with us
to completely pay off
the water bills for some families.
It was the people who actually
really made this work possible
by giving five dollars,
10 dollars, 20 dollars,
some of whom had been in this situation
themselves a few years prior,
where they couldn't afford
their own bills, but they now could,
so they were generous about it.
It was the people who held bake sales
to help people that they didn't know
and would never meet.
People see you walking the walk,
and you'll understand
that that compassion is contagious.
So I'd ask you in this moment then,
what is it
that sends you down a rabbit hole
of blog posts and news articles?
What leaves you so disgusted and annoyed
that you would rather skip work or class
and work on that instead?
What is that for you?
It's got to be something.
So suppose, for example,
you find out that the third graders
at your old elementary school
owe lunch money debt?
What if the most obvious
thing to do for them
is to pay off that lunch money debt,
sponsor some lunches, and then later on
go run for the local school board
to push for systemic change
around access to nutrition at school?
That's just an idea.
Now you might hear this and say,
"That's nice, it's cute,
but I don't really have time for that."
Or "Most problems are too big
to work on, so why bother?"
I'll say you're not unique
in thinking that at all.
But if we just stick with the idea
of doing the smallest at first,
the most obvious thing,
and just think about for a second,
what do you have the time,
what do you have the resources,
what do you have the skills
and the influence, even, to do?
To make happen.
For me, I was a programmer
with a whole day job,
so I didn't actually initially have time
to work on this all day either.
But using the skills and the resources
and the network that I did have,
we built out the original website
and then grew it from there.
So the next somewhat obvious
but I think hasty criticism
that we sometimes hear
is that what we did was just a band-aid.
That whatever you end up doing
is not going to be significant enough
is not going to make a difference,
it's too fleeting of a thing
to try to do to make a difference.
But is it not that the purpose
of a band-aid is to give an injury,
a place where something has gone wrong,
the opportunity to heal?
I'll say no,
initially, we weren't going to solve
the root of why people
couldn't afford their water bills.
And I'm not here to tell you either
that benevolent strangers sitting
at home in their pajamas
are a proper substitute
for systemic structural changes to issues.
But what I will tell you, though,
is that also, our solution
didn't attack the poverty,
it didn't attack the unemployment,
it didn't attack the bad public policy.
Yes, bad public policy
that enthusiastically punishes
people who are poor,
especially when they are Black or brown.
But what we did give people,
yes, what we did give people
in that moment is relief.
So again, whatever you do,
if it's small and if
it's an obvious thing,
it doesn't mean that your impact
can't actually be durable.
And that you shouldn't try
to do something.
And I say that because today,
we have helped over 5,000 people
with water bill payments just from --
(Applause)
Thank you.
Just from people again, giving
five dollars, 10 dollars, 50 dollars
whatever they can afford to contribute.
And our ripples of compassion
have actually gone even further.
We got a major American city to start
offering more compassionate assistance.
We had a US member of Congress
and their office reach out to get help
for their constituents.
We've had policymakers
in three different states
that we were able to help
using our data, our knowledge,
our experience
to understand what's happening
around water affordability
in their districts.
We've also been able to partner
with other nonprofits
and mutual aid groups
to keep families from facing eviction,
homelessness over their water bills.
We've also been able to help
families avoid facing the threat
of losing their kids.
I also now do this work full time
with the goal of helping
utilities understand
how to make water more affordable,
make water more of a human right,
so that people also don't fall behind
on their bills in the first place.
Legendary comedian Lily Tomlin once said,
"I always wondered why people
wouldn't do something about that.
Why somebody wouldn't do
something about that.
Then I realized I was somebody."
So you don't even actually have to be
a programmer to make a difference
or even do what I did.
You just have to be,
like Lily said, to be somebody.
Somebody who sees a thing
that can be fixed,
can be impacted,
and do that.
Do something.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)